TREY GOWEN SITTING IN FOR SEAN.
>> TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL EDITION
OF "HANNITY."
I’M TREY GOWDY IN TONIGHT FOR
SEAN.
WITH THANKSGIVING JUST DAYS
AWAY, DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY STAND READY AND ABLE TO
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT YOU CAN
AND CANNOT DO EVEN IF THEY ARE
UNWILLING TO FOLLOW THEIR OWN
RULES.
AND NOTHING IS OFF-LIMITS.
PENNSYLVANIAN’S SECRETARY JUST
ANNOUNCED A BAN ON ALCOHOL SALES
BEGINNING THIS WEDNESDAY AT
5:00 P.M.
THE STATE’S GOVERNOR IMPOSED AN
IN-HOME MASK MANDATE AND A TIME
THEY HAVE A VISITOR AND THEIR
DWELLING.
A SIMILAR RECOMMENDATION THAT
THEY USED IN NEVADA FORCING
RESIDENTS TO WEAR MASKS INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE AT ALL TIMES WHEN
AWAY FROM HOME.
A STATE WIDE 10:00 P.M. CURFEW
IS NOW IN EFFECT IN CALIFORNIA
FOR EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA
EXCEPT, OF COURSE,
GOVERNOR GAVIN.
NEW JERSEY IS UNDER AN EMERGENCY
ADVISOR LOCKDOWN AND THE RISKS
OF THE STATE IS FACING A TEN
PERSON LIMIT ON INDOOR
GATHERINGS.
GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY IS EVEN
ENCOURAGING FAMILY MEMBERS NOT
TO HUG EACH OTHER.
GOVERNOR MURPHY’S RULES APPLY TO
EVERYONE EXCEPT OF COURSE
GOVERNOR MURPHY HIMSELF, WHO
RECENTLY ENJOYED A MASK-FREE
NIGHT OUT WITH HIS FAMILY AT A
LOCAL RESTAURANT.
MEANWHILE, OREGON’S GOVERNOR,
KATE BROWN IS NOW URGING
RESIDENTS IN HER STATE TO CALL
THE POLICE AND REPORT ANY AND
ALL VIOLATIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU WANT PEOPLE CALLING
THE POLICE ON THEIR NEIGHBOR
NONEMERGENCY LINE?
>> LOOK, THIS IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HAPPENS IF THERE’S A
PARTY DOWN THE STREET AND IT’S
KEEPING EVERYONE AWAKE.
WHAT DO NEIGHBORS DO?
THEY CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE IT IS TOO NOISY.
>> THAT COULD BE A "YES."
>> YES, YES.
>> Trey: REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
SAME GOVERNOR WHO ALLOWED
PORTLAND TO DESCEND INTO ANARCHY
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS.
I KID YOU NOT.
GOVERNOR KATE BROWN WANTS YOU TO
CALL THE POLICE IF YOU SEE TOO
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS GATHERING.
BUT WHATEVER YOU DO, DON’T GET
THE POLICE INVOLVED WHEN THERE’S
LOOTING, AND WRITING, AND THE
FEDERAL COURTHOUSE IS ON FIRE OR
UNDER ASSAULT.
BUT EVEN THAT, IT MAY NOT BE AS